you
hi everyone it's Jerry the Alaska trap
is a trap for black out of the alb
encounter gambit in it y can easily fall
victim to an extremely rare and
devastating tactic involving a mere pond
let's see how this black deep pond in
particular could turn out to be very
deadly and along the way pay close
attention to this Queen h4 move as it'll
be present in a few of the sub
variations I show
so after d4 d5 and c4 the Queens gambit
with E 5 we have the Albin counter
gambit D takes E and D for robbing the
Queen Knight of this c3 square now a
very common idea is to challenge an
opposing pawn that's in your territory
with one of your own pawns the move III
does just that however in this instance
it's already a step in the wrong
direction for white Bishop b4 with check
and after the counter attacking Bishop
d2 this threat against the bishop is one
that black can ignore with D takes E and
before I get into the type of beating
white will end up taking if Bishop takes
Bishop let me just point out that the
best continuation for white is to
immediately recapture on e3 and should
that come about here's how black can at
least regain the material lost Queen h4
with check and after g3 Queen e4 and pay
particular attention to what exactly the
Queen is doing not only hitting the rook
and the pawn on e5 but also the one on
e3 keep in mind the bishop is pinned and
in short the material the pawn will be
won back in black is doing quite alright
reverting back to this position if
instead of F takes equi nay four were
played we would have the knight blocking
the check and after Bishop takes Bishop
pawn takes pawn would ensue King takes
pawn and yet again Queen h4 with check
pawn g3 Queen to d4 with check and
however you slice it no matter where the
King goes the h1 rook the a1 rook will
fall for example if King to g2 or e2
it's queen takes B
and then queen takes the rook on a if
the King runs home we have Queen e4 and
it's the rook on h1 that falls and
lastly if King f3 we have Bishop check
King G to Queenie for the rook on h1 yet
again will fall finally what occurs
after Bishop takes Bishop from this
position is pon takes pawn width check
trying to deflect the King away from
defense of the Queen King to e2 is the
only way to maintain defense of the
Queen but now comes the devastating pawn
takes Knight under promoting to a night
with check this is all very important as
otherwise capturing the knight and
promoting to a queen allows white one
moment to breathe and in that moment
there's Queen takes Queen King takes
Queen and only then the recapture and
the material is balanced however under
promoting to a knight lands a check and
now after rook takes Knight we would
just have Bishop g4 this is lights out
for the queen is dead and the other line
would be king e 1 and now yet again
Queen to h4 if g3 we have Queen to e4
and the rook is dead and if King to d2
we have a tricky Knight coming out with
tempo the bishop coming out screaming
down at the Queen black queenside
castling giving a check to the king and
not to mention black is still up a piece
you